all right our first headline is in the
auto racing world NASCAR Daytona 500
you know they kick off the season with
like their biggest race and a massive
crash which took out about half the race
22 drivers in all were taken out with
about nine laps left massive crash at
Daytona
Erica played a clip one more time yeah I
mean you can hear that it was yeah I
mean it was a crazy crash how many cars
Greg 21 21 out of 50 50 50 cars started
the race 21 involved in that crash and
at the time I think 10 of them were even
off before that so that's like more than
half of the competitors out with in one
turn I love that I wish that happened in
more sports imagine if like imagine if
like again on one play in the NFL half
the players got hurt half the players
have like season-ending injuries on just
one play it would be like the equivalent
I think of as Heinz would kick Hines
Ward's kick off the turn and the Dark
Knight Rises when the entire field class
is behind him in both teams dot everyone
on the field dies except for Hines Ward
the deadlies play in NFL history like
that would I think I think more sports
should have this sort of catastrophic
possibility when you have the threat of
potential death at all times doesn't it
make the actual event like more meaning
meaning it's like that's why old older
people often say you know if as long as
they you know don't get the penis cancer
they the end of their life is some of
the happiest because they're aware at
any moment that it could have all been
over and you appreciate it more yeah I
didn't really take that angle I just
thought it's more fun to watch like if
like I get MMA fight or a boxing fight
there's a chance that it could go 12
rounds there's a chance that it could be
over in five seconds you know if someone
gets a knocked out and I wish they had
any more sports like I think in
basketball they should blind the players
that way you just slam into someone and
it's over you know you could run into
the backboard you can run into stands by
mistake and kill yourself and that'll be
the end of the game and that would be so
much more fun to watch the game wait how
would they be blind what do you mean
with like with the like throwing stuff
in their eyes or they would have a
blindfold or what I think
we'd want to make it permanent once you
get to the body level like in high
school you would blindfold them in
college you'd probably throw something
in their eyes that would blind them like
periods of time and then when you get
the NFL you got to pluck them out yeah
you got to take them with a spoon like
in Slumdog Millionaire yeah yeah yeah
Slumdog Millionaire and then I think the
NBA you'd get to your seat before the
game started cuz you're like I don't
know how long it's gonna go I paid a lot
of money for these tickets and I don't
know what's up I
I like let's say baseball if after when
you swung the bat you had to let go of
it like you had to let go of it on your
swing think about how much more exciting
Major League Baseball would be how long
is the pitcher gonna pitch could be one
pitch could be the whole game you don't
know cuz the bats coming at him I like
how they just act like the announcers
all took it in totally in stride I mean
they were kind of like wow this is a big
one that they're gone to the big one and
they're just in like there was a little
bit of silence and then the guy was just
like well that ruined everything I think
though I think that's like it didn't
seem like that crate like they weren't
worried at all about the safety of the
drivers or anything Lee just because
that's part of the sport it wasn't I
mean if you heard the crash I think you
got all the information you need do you
hear the announcers pontificate about it
like yeah I could play the crash again
yeah when you hear something like that
one of the announcers gonna do how you
gonna add to that you can't unless you
go back and talk about Heinz woods kick
off the deadliest the deadliest play in
the NFL I think that's a lot of the
reason why they got rid of they're
trying to get rid of the kick off you
know a lot of more touch backs now cuz
it finds them work because I mean
because of the teammates Hines lost that
day right when they when they like run
the stats and it's like oh the average
fatalities on kickoff returns are way
higher than any other play mm-hmm but
that's all just signs word and just
after that play is when they executed a
nuclear physicist to write on the field
in front of everyone which you know I
think the NFL needs more that tennis
legend Martina Navratilova got was in
the news this week by writing an op-ed
in The Sunday Times in London
saying that it's insane and cheating for
transgender women to compete in sports
olympics bicycles anything never in my
life did I think Martina Navratilova
would speak out against trans people if
anyone has an ally you would think it
would be it would be Martina Navratilova
like who is a you know a woman but could
pass for trans let's say she could make
it that her speaking out is it's the
last person I would ever expect and I
love when people speak out against
things that won't affect them and could
not possibly affect them ever like
Martina Navratilova does not compete
anymore there has no like why is she
talking about this at all
and let's go to what she said that trans
people competing in any sport or in
tennis is insane and cheating is it
cheating yes but so is using a racket
and everyone turns a blind eye to that
is it insane again I have to agree with
her that in today's day and age I think
trans people have better things to do
than play tennis that if I had a trans
daughter or son I would not let them
play tennis I would have I would have
more activities for them mmm - do you
know what hockey I think I think Trent
the trans community could excel at
hockey I think the trans community would
be great at soccer
I think the trans community dominate
could dominate the NFL if they chose to
what's very strange is they're really
good at swimming diving I think I think
running still going
track-and-field pole vault but tennis
get the out of my face the topic
didn't even come up having to do with
tennis it has to do with the cyclist
that she randomly decided to back you
know the microphone is picking up you
opening the turkey jerky bag Anthony
when you talk about dropping the ball
and professionalism when I want to show
disrespect
while I'm working strictly for
disrespect I mean it worked
she was talking about a cyclist but my
favorite thing is she kind of got caught
up in this by saying this wasn't fair
back in October and she says then she
spent the ensuing months researching the
topic so that she could be better suited
to write this opinion piece which I
loved the image of that like Martina
Navratilova spent the last three months
just researching trans topic and she got
like deep into it in terms of like
hormones and man men have muscle and
bone density and they can't measure that
it's like something better to do now the
stories getting stranger it's this
sounds to me like she got caught looking
at trans porn and tried to cover it up
by bailing noses for a research project
researching and she was like let me say
something and just get out of the way
before I get embarrassed yeah I didn't
it wasn't like in the 70s or something
there was like a trans woman or guy yeah
what ran a race or did something and
they were like oh this is going to like
men are going to become trans so they
can win medals and that never happened
like no one no one has that priority
right Renee Richards who played tennis I
believe was kind of the first famous
yeah and it was tennis it was tennis I
think there's a 13 34 30 on it but yeah
that whole thing sounds very in you know
she's been called transphobic that her
big argument was that what's to stop you
know a woman from a man from doing it
and then you know chanting then they get
the trophies and then they change their
mind and make some babies then then they
can go back to wanting to like be a
woman and make babies like that's yeah
it's a long way to go and also imagine
like that person like it has no bragging
rights whatsoever it's like yeah I
pulled a fast one on them I got sick of
these chicks and they're getting their
trophies so I thought I'd uh I thought
I'd go through a long and painful
procedure and then win some and then
switch it back I'm not under full yeah
it's it's hilarious that she came out
with it just it's
old person talking about old person
things America anything you want to add
any other sports you think trans people
would be good at um field hockey field
hockey
that's one lacrosse across I think
they'd be awesome at horse riding or
equestrianism mm-hmm equestrianism is
what they call it
curling mm-hmm curling crop sledding
bobsledding regular sledding mm-hmm
skiing snowboarding sweating what is
regular sledding waterskiing CrossFit
like that's not like a real thing but
like video games yeah video games I
think trans people would be good at
chess chess checkers ping pong that's
too close too close to tennis you know
badminton I wouldn't put in there
basically the transcommunity
stay away from rackets and paddles in
that way and we don't have a problem you
got other sports you're good at
you don't need tennis Erica before we
move on one more time I'll play the clip
of the crash Wow
[Music]
you